I am welcome back to politics this
episode is kind of split into two halves
the first half I'm just gonna finish off
this Main Street to some extent that I
feel like I can transition into the rest
of the park and work on that as well and
in the second part in the second part of
this video I'm actually going to try
that and see if I can build my first
real themed roller coaster something to
note about that though is that the last
couple of minutes of this episode are
missing since I was trying to record me
doing the scenery and foliage offset
roller coaster and then I forgot that my
entire HDD was already riddled with too
many videos and fraps filled to record a
video after that parts which is why this
video is a bit short and and a bit
before I would have liked it to end but
I don't think that's too big of an issue
there's a couple of things I also want
to say about the first video of this
series I've got some feedback about you
know the time-lapse sort of structure
that I have to these videos and whether
some people actually wanted to get some
real-time gameplay as well as time
lapses but I do have to say about that
I'm probably not going to do it I went
with this entire idea of time lapse in
my videos simply because well I'm not
too great of a life letsplayer myself I
think anyway but I just kind of liked
playing the video on my own or live
streaming I mean I like kind of like
playing the game on my own or live
streaming it and then just speed it up
and I just do this and provides
commentary over it since I feel like
it's a bit better than just slapping
random music over it and if people
really want to listen to music while
watching this I suppose you can always
open a new tab with music that you like
a mute this video actually heard that
some people to listen to my videos but
don't watch them which is pretty funny
as well so yeah that's pretty much about
that that being said I do think I might
want to do some real time tours of the
parks after I finish them employers like
since I'm obviously not gonna be able to
do cinematic footage as I can in Veliko
second three so I think I do have real
time sort of let's play playthroughs of
the Pyke's that I make in the end and
what I might do but I'm not even sure
about that is to
the coaster designs real-time but the
issue is with that that I do take quite
a lot of time sometimes to make my
coasters there's gonna be a woody in
this series somewhere and that took over
an hour to make and even if I cut into
that it's gonna be either very long
real-time footage of me trying to build
a coaster and endlessly failing or it's
gonna be weird
cut it short sections of video
everywhere which I don't think really
works for this type of game so yeah
that's about that that being said though
I am pretty much hooked to this game
already and the community is really
awesome and I'm very surprised actually
by all the awesome positive feedback on
the first video hours almost varying a
bit of a lukewarm reception of that
video since I figured it would be maybe
too big niche content and I don't know
of people who were interested in what
lack of circuitry would actually be
interested in this game but so far it
actually sort of seems to reflect my
enthusiasm so I'm really happy about
that
and how I haven't even really talked
about the stuff that happens in this
video yet but honestly it's not really
too interesting I don't know if I've
really thoroughly described which sort
of theme I'm trying to go for in this
park but I'm gonna get a bit of a Alpine
ish theme which is gonna be very tough
since there aren't any of the well
typically Alpine pieces yet some very
fundamental things are still missing but
it's the overall sort of atmosphere that
I try to go for which is why I have all
these very standard roofs and I'm trying
as much as I can to avoid using these
Pacific Western facades but still I do
have to say if anybody who doesn't know
that I currently only two building sets
out for this game one is the generic
building set and one is a Western
building set which makes it kind of
tough to actually try other themes as
well but I think you've seen some people
and try to meet somebody actually made a
agen Park already which is really
awesome so yeah there's a lot there's a
lot of versatility in how you can use
the pieces and that's basically what I'm
trying to get at with this scenery over
here that being said also keep in mind
that most of the videos that I'll upload
in the upcoming period and this is also
something that was
we discussed in the comment section of
the last video is the fact that much of
the videos which are watching right now
are pre-recorded and quite a while too
right now that I'm commentating over
this it's already a couple of days ago
but I've already worked five episodes
ahead as we speak so when it comes to
new mods that come out it's very
outdated but also when it comes to
giving feedback on the park if you think
there's anything that I should improve
upon you can always say it but at the
moment I'm already a couple of episodes
ahead so it's going to take quite a
while to actually get that feedback into
the park so that's something to keep in
mind and about the rest over here I was
basically figuring you can see Bill well
contrast in how I was trying to build
the Main Street and how I'm trying to
build the rest of the park since I
initially started out thinking that I
would turn this into a bit of a
Disneyland a pre-planned park which
would have certain areas and a perfectly
symmetrical layouts but I think in the
end I don't want to go for that so it's
really only something that you can see
in the main street and the rest of this
park will just be very improvised won't
really have any specific areas and I'll
just much more focus on individual
attractions and places and this is
basically where I start working on that
first little junior coaster over here
which is going to be the first real
themed coaster that I ever make in this
game I've tried to build a couple of
especially steel coasters and the number
of other types really just to try them
and see how the coaster creative works
and see if I can kind of get used to it
and this was pretty much to the point
where I felt confident enough that I
could actually build a simple roller
coaster like this that being said it's
gonna turn into one big fest of helixes
I think in hindsight I probably should
have kept it down on the helixes just a
little bit more but I do sort of like it
I suppose it's good for a first little
roller coaster in this game it's um
fine etiquette for anybody who's played
the original RCT I was kind of inspired
by gentle Glenn which is a scenario over
here to get this sort of colorful purple
colour scheme going and kind of let this
junior coaster ride over the hills and
things like
which it is pretty good for though so
far it's been sort of tough since this
roller coaster type doesn't really have
any sort of steep slopes and yeah this
was pretty much my first test of the
layouts and it really felt too short it
was still very fast at the end of the
layouts I don't know of the friction the
friction settings are gonna be adjusted
in the future but it does seem at the
moment like especially this coaster type
doesn't have a lot of friction it takes
a very long layout actually slowed down
enough to get some decent speed going to
head into the station but yeah that's
probably also one of the reasons why
there are so many helixes in the in this
ride I did want to fill a certain area
and I wanted it to be quite large but I
didn't want this right to ever reach
very high speeds since it's pretty much
my junior coaster in this park and it's
already quite large and heavily themed
for a junior coaster so it's already a
bit of an experiment in that sort of
sense and I say theming but it's really
not gonna be too well themed don't
expect too much I'm just gonna plop down
some random little wooden cabins and a
small observation tower and some simple
foliage rockwork cross things like that
I'm very sorry that you're gonna have to
miss me building that stuff I probably
should have actually looked at the FPS
counter of fraps which if you don't know
if you're recording in fraps the FPS
counter turns red so you know that
you're recording and if it stops
recording the FPS counter turns yellow
so you kind of know that you're not
recording at that point but I always
forget to look at that thing so I was
happily building on this closed room
trying to record my let's play but in
the meantime it already stopped
recording so that was kind of clumsy but
yeah this is the basic sort of ride
really not too heavily themed the
station is pretty simple as well it was
more of a tests to kind of see how this
would work out but I'm still quite happy
about it and the terraforming is
religious because I felt like it was a
bit simple and repetitive to just have
simple grass everywhere so I wanted to
get this
know exactly what it is if it's a darker
shade of cross it seems to be a darker
shade of grass but looking at it right
like this it also kind of looks like
some some muddy sort of texture but yeah
I kind of wanted to get that in get a
bit of a swamp
ish look going around the water
especially and later on just plop down
random logs random little objects that
you can place like barrels and small
boxes it's kind of decorated but yeah
again kind of missing out on that this
was also been inspired by forest
frontiers the first scenario which kind
of also had those little houses in the
middle of the forest to just make it
look a bit less repetitive and actually
have very light steaming without making
the entire right well kind of like a
Disneyland theme rollercoaster and yeah
that's the basic thing from this
observation tower I'll just be doing
some simple foliage and simple
decorations around the ride but I'm
sorry you're gonna have to miss that and
you'll see it in the next episode I
suppose so see you that